Your favorite superhero may be able to deflect
bullets, but can they draw in the energy from
every living creature on earth, fuse
it all into a giant ball of energy,
and chuck it at a bubblegum-colored maniac
threatening to destroy our entire planet?
The moment you feel certain about your grasp of
power levels in Dragon Ball, prepare to have that
certainty slip through your fingers as each
character continues their ascension to glory.
Whether it be stepping into the hyperbolic time
chamber for a few days to train for a few years
or a synchronized dance with a companion
to merge into a more powerful super-being,
each new development in the series has shown that
there are countless ways to amplify power levels.
Over 30 years of lore has created plenty
of ammo for each side of any argument.
For that reason, let's narrow things down a bit.
There are many powerful characters throughout
the show, but we want to stick with the best of
the best - to a point. It's understandable
that we would leave Zeno, the Omni-King,
off the list. Not only because he doesn't fight,
but also because the supreme ruler of the entire
multiverse who can blink gods, mortals, and an
entire universe out of existence in an instant
would make for a boring anti-climactic
finish to an otherwise juicy debate.
Dragon Ball Super contains major players from
across an expansive multiverse, but a majority
of the series takes place in Universe 7, where
the Z Fighters reside on Earth. Other universes
are home to powerful warriors as well, such as the
Pride Troopers of Universe 11. Excluding numerous
fusions and reducing any transformations to their
core character has resulted in this completely
comprehensive list that will in no way enrage
any fans of the phenomenal anime series. Onward!
New villains crop up in Dragon Ball Z with every
new arc. Each confrontation forces our heroes to
push themselves beyond known limits, to the point
that some characters have become nigh-godlike in
power. But there is one being whose immense
power challenges even the strongest fighters:
Cell. This bio-android has spent years
obliterating every opponent thrown at him. He's so
powerful that writers had to introduce different
timelines in order for him to be defeated.
Even then, he manages to take control of time and
travel backwards, to make himself even stronger.
Cell was created by a supercomputer using cells
from some of the universe's strongest heroes.
He is able to increase his power by
draining energy from other entities,
which is why he roams the Earth, drinking
up the life forces of entire cities.
"I owe it all to this worthless planet for
providing me with the bio extract I needed."
Cell is, without question, one of the strongest
life forms in existence. The only reason for him
being at the bottom of this list is because of his
recent absence from the Dragon Ball Z storyline.
Fans haven't seen Cell since GT, when he
is briefly allied with another villain
and defeated by Goku, but GT isn't considered
part of the canon. Cell's power has not grown
in quite some time but given his uniquely adaptive
powers, he shouldn't ever be counted out for good.
This lean, green, fighting
machine originally trained
to become one of the Supreme Kais of Universe 10.
"This is my apprentice the
Supreme Kai in training, Zamasu."
"It is a pleasure to make your acquaintance."
He is well respected among the other Kais for
his superior intellect and massive knowledge base
— plus, he can brew a mean cup of tea. Now, you
might disagree with Zamasu's ranking on this list,
but remember: We are talking about the characters'
core forms. All the scenarios that lead to Zamasu
becoming insanely unbeatable are created by
his Dragon Ball wish. Plus, things don't get
completely out of hand until he merges with Goku
Black. Things get so nuts, Zeno the Omni-King
has to literally wipe the entire universe in
order to cancel out Zamasu's invincibility.
Zamasu's misguided sense of universal
justice is the most imposing thing about him:
He views humanity as detrimental to
existence, and seeks to wipe it out.
His Dragon Ball wish for immortality, plus
his merging with Goku Black, transform him
into a massive ethereal entity which envelops the
universe. Yet at his core, Zamasu isn't too tough.
Goku easily defeats Zamasu in combat in his base
form, and Trunks later slices him in half by
embodying all of humanity in his sword. Granted,
that slice unleashes an unbeatable cosmic being
that begins raining destruction on the entire
fabric of reality. But hey, we say he cheated.
It might be the way his soothing
lavender hair flaps in the wind.
It may be his stylish jean
jacket. Whatever the reason,
Trunks has been a fan favorite for decades. He
first appears as a mysterious young boy capable of
transforming into a Super Saiyan. We later learn
that he is the offspring of Vegeta and Bulma -
"She's my mom."
"WWOOOOAHHH!! So Vegeta and Bulma?!"
- and has traversed several timelines
before settling into the one we know today.
His father's cocky, arrogant demeanor
is tempered by his mother's humanity,
resulting in a cool, level-headed warrior.
Ranking Trunks' power level is complicated,
given his time-traveling nature. We've seen
Future Trunks achieve greatness, but the main
storyline currently features Trunks as a young,
playful kid. He also tends to implement a
right-place-right-time fighting technique
that dazzles, but doesn't display much
sustainability. The promise of Future
Trunks places him on a pedestal among fans — one
he deserves. But all these competing factors make
us reluctant to place him anywhere but just
below legendary status. Trunks is no slouch:
He has helped the gang defeat Cell, beat the tar
out of Frieza, and sliced an immortal in half.
Trunks is entirely worthy of the praise he
receives. But we're still waiting for more.
The Tournament of Power mashes several universes
together. Among those are the Saiyans of Universe
6, where Kale is their version of the legendary
Super Saiyan. Kale shows up at the Tournament
of Power as a meek, timid fighter paired with
her mentor, Caulifla. After Goku enrages her,
Kale reveals her true power by transforming
into the legendary Super Saiyan. Kale is so
powerful that she marches unharmed through a
kamehameha attack from Super Saiyan Blue Goku,
and then unleashes a barrage of uncontrolled
energy blasts at everyone in the vicinity.
Much like her Universe 7 counterpart Broly,
Kale's base power level is seemingly limitless.
The downside to this genetic trait is
that her form is a berserker state,
rooted in rage and difficult to control.
The normally docile Kale has yet to undergo
the years of training we've seen other heroes go
through, so as of right now, Kale is all promise.
She hasn't had enough time for her character
to develop, but we'll likely see Kale rise
through the ranks to become one of the strongest
characters in all of the Dragon Ball franchise.
For a long time, Broly technically wasn't
considered part of the Dragon Ball canon.
Thankfully, fans latched on to their
favorite rage monster and never let go.
In 2018, Dragon Ball Super: Broly was released,
officially bringing this outrageously strong
character into the canon. Broly was born in
a pod next to Goku on the Saiyan home planet.
His power was so great that it scared King
Vegeta, who ordered Broly and his father executed.
This decision stoked the primal fury now
synonymous with his legendary bloodline.
Broly's tragic path in life leaves him
devoid of any appropriate training for
his immense power. When faced with challenges,
Broly simply calls forth more power and bashes
the problem in with his fists. His story is
left open-ended in Dragon Ball Super: Broly,
implying we have yet to see just
how strong Broly can truly become.
Some may think Broly should be much higher
on this list, but he lacks adaptability.
He may be a bottomless pit of raw power, but
he's just not honed. Still, it's a bit scary
to imagine what he might be capable of, given
the proper training and some caring friends.
"There's plenty of stuff I wanna
teach him too if he's interested."
Majin Buu
pink mass possesses a unique ability to turn
his enemies into chocolate and absorb their
power by eating them — adding a layer of terror
icing to an extremely unpredictable villain.
Majin Buu was created by a warlock many
years before the main characters were born;
upon release from his imprisonment, he showed that
there is no controlling his childlike emotions.
His lack of control adds many challenges
to an already formidable enemy.
No other character in all of Dragon Ball has shown
as many different forms and transformations as
Majin Buu, morphing numerous times based on
his emotional responses and eating habits.
Though his regenerative ability combines with his
power level to create a seemingly unbeatable foe,
Buu is a slave to his emotions. Ego and reason
play second fiddle to his reactive persona,
resulting in a lack of technique and passion
needed to rise up against new challenges.
It is for this reason that such an impregnable
character finds himself at the bottom of the list.
It goes without saying that the son of
the first Super Saiyan would inherit a
solid amount of power through genetics alone.
Gohan has shown time and again in moments of
crisis that there is an immense amount
of power lying inside his docile heart.
His strongest aspects shine through in his
protective instincts, drawing power from a
limitless well of energy when seeing his loved
ones in danger. At times he displays a power
beyond that of Super Saiyan, surpassing even
Goku. It is Gohan who, while not delivering
the final blow, ultimately defeats the bio-android
Cell when the rest of Earth's heroes have fallen.
Despite all that power, Gohan's Saiyan fighting
instincts are tempered by some of his more human
attributes. The desire to fight and grow stronger
are of little interest to this gentle soldier.
His interests lie in raising a family and
studying to become a renowned scholar.
With training and a drive to surpass his
competitors, there is no doubt that Gohan could
become a fighter of extremely potent power and
prestige. Alas, his preference for a simple life
lowers this member of the endangered Saiyan
race down near the bottom of the list.
"Oh sorry I didn't ask, are you more of a
vanilla guy? If so then take this one, I'm easy."
"No it's not a problem, chocolate's fine."
"I'm a softy for soft serve!"
"Uh, yeah."
This stoic assassin emerged as a fierce competitor
in his battle with Goku in the Tournament of
Power. Known among Universe 6 as the "Legendary
Assassin," Hit possesses an extremely unique and
powerful ability in Time-Skip — which allows him
to manipulate time and skip forward a tenth of
a second, which is hugely significant once you
move as fast as the characters on this list do.
Hit combines his Time-Skip
ability with his Phoenix Eye Fist
to focus his attacks into one point
and aim at his opponents vital organs.
Given that the trenchcoat-clad hitman
is also over a thousand years old,
he also has a vast amount of experience. He can
rapidly adapt to his fighting situation, shown
in his ability to improve his Time-Skip for even
larger chunks of time in his fight against Goku.
"Somehow he's figured out how to improve his
fighting move in the middle of this match,
without any boost to his power!"
While his rare ability allows for a large
advantage, once his opponents study his moves,
they're able to predict where he'll
go next and defend appropriately.
This leaves something lacking in this
incredible fighter's raw base power.
The primary antagonist in the Dragon Ball
series, Frieza, appears multiple times as Goku's
arch-nemesis. He plays a major part in the Saiyan
timeline as the character responsible for the
destruction of their homeworld, the obliteration
of the planet Namek, personally killing Vegeta's
father, and has led multiple invasions of
Earth. The Emperor of Universe 7 possesses
an incredible knack for drawing upon vast amounts
of energy. His strongest, original form is buried
beneath a series of transformations in order
to help his body contain his incredible might.
Frieza is extremely hard to kill and
is so talented as a fighter that he
achieved his Golden form with
only four months of training.
His power is second only to his enormous
ego, which is damaged so badly by his defeat
to Goku that it takes him years of mental
training for him to regain his strength.
The mark of a true villain shines through in
Frieza's cruelty via torture and genocide.
"What's he thinking? No! The Frieza Force!"
"Did he really wipe out his
entire army just to make a point?"
Should this tyrant be able to temper his
arrogance and psychopathic tendencies,
he will no doubt rival the
universe's strongest heroes.
The Pride Troopers of Universe 11 are
led by the husky warrior known as Toppo.
Despite his rotund stature, the candidate for
the next God of Destruction is deceptively fast
and shrouds all his actions in an extra-thick
layer of justice. His specialties in battle
lie not only in his energy blasts, but in close
quarter combat via debilitating locks and holds.
While his base power level is already
crazy strong, once his energy surges,
displayed by a menacing purple aura, it reveals
Toppo's true power — enabling an easy victory
of Frieza's golden form. While usually
displaying respect to his fellow fighters,
he also has a bit of a temper which can disrupt
his normally level-headed fighting style.
Desperation causes Toppo to abandon his
principles in the pursuit of victory,
which ultimately leads to his
defeat at the hands of Vegeta.
An infinite supply of anger courses
through the Saiyan bloodline in the form
of Prince Vegeta. Originally destined
to rule his doomed home planet,
the reluctant anti-hero's power levels
always seem to be just a step behind
Earth's strongest — occasionally crossing
into the mightiest of the Dragon Ball
pantheon through displays of pure rage. Few
are liked by the sardonic warrior prince
and even fewer are as dedicated to the achievement
of ultimate power. Vegeta's dedication to martial
arts and the cultivation of his ki [CHEE] are
unparalleled. Combined with his regal bloodline,
these characteristics make for one of the
most dominant fighters in the universe.
While he repeatedly says Goku is his mortal enemy,
his actions show respect and acknowledgement in
the competitive drive supplied by his Saiyan
companion. Once sent to Earth in the form
of an enemy in search of the dragon balls, his
disdain for "Kakarot" [KAK-are-rot] is pacified
by his desire to pass him in terms of power.
He repeatedly falls short in this endeavor as
his anger tends to overwhelm him and cause him to
rush into dangerous situations without analysis.
An extraordinarily high opinion
of himself results in Vegeta
underestimating his opponents and charging in
ill-prepared. His immense amount of pride calls
forth endless pools of power and at other
times serves as a debilitating weakness.
"I don't care how powerful you are -
I will be the one who defeats you and
claims the super dragon balls!"
Regardless, he continues to be one
of Universe 7's strongest heroes.
The backstory of this stoic fighter
is wrought with death and loneliness.
"Jiren hasn't moved a muscle yet."
"Yeah, nor would I expect him to. That's
kind of his schtick, the whole stoic thing."
As a child, Jiren lost his parents and his
entire village to a villainous demon who,
in a later confrontation, also killed his master.
This resulted in a lifetime of dedication
to strength and honor and until he joined
the Pride Soldiers, Jiren spent a large
portion of his life alone in his training.
The most impressive aspect of this burly fighter
lies not in transformation, but in the ability to
sustain his energy levels through incredible
displays of strength and endurance.
He is viewed as the most powerful warrior
in Universe 11 and is the only mortal
capable of defeating their God of Destruction.
In one of the most climactic
moments in Dragon Ball Super,
Goku transforms into his most powerful form yet,
Ultra Instinct. But even in this ultimate form,
Jiren simply draws forth even more energy to
continue battling toe-to-toe with the Saiyan.
Most of the fighters in the universe use
transformations to temporarily multiply their
power beyond what is normally
sustainable for their bodies.
Jiren employs a mostly defensive style that
forces his opponents to exhaust themselves,
allowing for his attacks to land with devastating
results. While Jiren possesses a herculean amount
of power, his life has resulted in an almost
cold disposition that leaves no room for
emotion — which happens to be the greatest source
of strength for the series' primary protagonist.
The Dragon Ball series begins with Goku as
a child teaming up with Bulma in a hunt for
the mythical Dragon Balls. All these years later,
the loveable defender of Earth continues to grow
in strength while maintaining a gentle disposition
that seems to disarm even the Gods of Destruction.
Seemingly devoid of any negative emotions, Goku
has ambitions that stem from his desire to protect
those he loves. It is in moments of despair, when
his loss in battle would spell death for those
around him, that the Saiyan draws forth epic
new levels of power to overwhelm his enemies.
Whether it be through his signature move
the Kamehameha, or by channeling ki from
nearby lifeforms to form the almighty Spirit
Bomb, the admirable hero always finds a way.
Goku was met with another moment of desperation
in the final minutes of the Tournament of Power.
With the losers of the tournament facing
the destruction of their universe,
our favorite Saiyan displays a fighting
form normally reserved for the gods in Ultra
Instinct — a transformation in which the mind
separates from the body, leaving it to operate on
pure instinct. Though others may seem stronger at
first, Goku has shown us repeatedly that few can
match the limitless well of energy that flows
through the cheery protector of Universe 7.
This catlike humanoid shows a level of
indifference to most lifeforms that could
only be reserved for an entity of cosmic
power. Beerus seems to harbor no ill will
towards any lifeforms, merely annoyance at
any disruptions in his favorite activities,
acting mostly as a mechanism of
nature. As a God of Destruction,
he is served with the duty of maintaining balance
in Universe 7, which he enacts through the
decimation of any planet that displease him. The
imposing entity has existed for millions of years,
which adds quite a bit of experience to
the gourmet-loving god's remarkable power.
While Goku seems to be evenly matched with him at
certain points, it is apparent that Beerus did not
come close to unleashing his full potential. He is
able to nullify the energy of most mortals and can
launch devastating attacks with his Sphere
of Destruction and has a base power level
which needs no transformation or amplification.
Most mortals cower before his fickle appetites,
but there is someone who quite literally
schools him in terms of strength and technique.
When we first meet this lean, aloof individual,
it is not readily apparent that great power
lies behind his carefree smile. While Beerus
zips around the universe imposing his will on
anyone who dares annoy him, Whis stands by
his side — appearing as no more than a gentle
companion, complacent in running trivial errands.
As the story unwinds, it becomes clearer that the
immortal angel possesses an unfathomable amount
of power. When Beerus begins destroying worlds
after consuming wasabi, Whis knocks him out with
a single chop to the neck. In Dragon Ball Super,
he appears to exert little effort in a sparring
session against both Goku and Vegeta, even going
as far as autographing the unwitting Saiyan's
outfits in the middle of their dual onslaught.
Whis has the ability to rewind time up to
three minutes without creating any paradoxes
or time loops — a necessary power when one's sole
responsibility is to mitigate the powers of a God
of Destruction. Despite all these abilities,
his effortless displays of speed and strength
come paired with a penchant for table
manners and a love of Earth cuisine.
There is no other being in
Universe 7 with as much power,
which makes his serene disposition all the more
sensible. What need is there for any displays of
anxiety or negative emotion when nothing in your
realm of existence is capable of causing you harm?
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
powerful anime characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.